Oh
probably a lot of times and I probably
have a lot of regrets to it's baloney
people say no to either of those things
back in 2009 after the whole Miss
California miss USA incident some people
started to see me as more than just that
blogger with crazy hair some people
started to see me as a human being
because I was talking about things that
they didn't necessarily associate with
me and I started to really let that
affect me and that's not a bad thing but
I love the fact that you know most
people ninety-nine percent of people in
the general public don't know who I am
the real me but if you do read my
website and you read my website daily
several times a day those people know
who I am and what I'm all about and you
know it's what they say that matters to
me not what people who don't know me or
get me say about me
I'm just things like you know you're an
embarrassment for the gay community why
is he out there on Larry King talking
about this we should have somebody else
I'm like well why not mean I am a gay
man who is affected by this issue I'm
talking for me about me about my reality
sharing my story which a lot of people
can relate to
I'm still shocked at the amount of media
attention and discourse that one
question at a beauty pageant was able to
bring about and I'm really happy that I
had opportunities to speak out for
marriage equality even though I'm not a
spokesperson for the gay community and
I've never claimed to be and I'm happy
that I went through that experience it
wasn't easy I got a lot of hate mail but
I also got a lot of positive mail from
people that really appreciated that I
was speaking up for myself
you know I've regretted a lot of things
probably my biggest regret was when I
said Fidel Castro was dead because yeah
that turned out to not be true but I had
really good information at the time
which turned out to be really wrong